okay well I can't stay over tonight
because I have to wake up early in the
morning okay it's 10 p.m. what you have
to wake up early just come inside for a
second just for a minute
fine but only for one minute okay okay
what what the hell is this David okay
honey honey I need you to relax okay
and calm down and just walk right over
there okay just take a seat no just come
on um so Ellie thank you for being here
tonight you know that we all care about
you
right we wouldn't be here if we didn't
you have problems what I mean we don't
want you to feel like you're being
attacked okay because you're not no
we're just trying to help you okay maybe
you have a problem that I feel like this
is the issue that needs to be addressed
okay yeah oh my god is this a frickin
intervention because if it is y'all know
I've not touched a single ounce of meth
in like three years so I don't know look
we're not talking about when did you do
meth it's a couple years ago I mean a
couple you had a couple guys no no who
would no no I just wanna thought she
said a couple guys I just want to talk
to it a cup wonder than it is it was
James and Eric wasn't it no it's cool
not cool no I'm cool hey listen Allie
we're all here tonight to talk about a
habit of yours that's been affecting us
as a group have it I don't I don't
understand it's not about you it's about
us but you need to stop singing
thank you is this a joke what about my
singing oh wait you're not understanding
what I'm trying to say I'm saying you
can't sing as in you're not good Chris
I'm a classically trained vocalist from
when I was like in the city no no no no
I can't do this you suck do you
understand
you suck yo yo I didn't want to have to
do this but this girl right here y'all
shan't get what we're trying to tell her
all right
you sound horrible you sound horrible
you sound like a tone-deaf Indian woman
singing I handle on the bus do you have
something constructive to say yeah looky
Ali you know I don't say much but beyond
singing horribly it's the way you go
about your singing that's the problem
like Peters you know when somebody hears
a song on a radio that they really like
what do they usually do well they turn
it up and they sing exactly but what do
you do hey oh my god I love this song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like why can't you just tell us the name
of the song that you like why do you
always have to sing it oh my god G oh I
just heard this new sound on the radio
and I'm totally obsessed with it I have
it on repeat what's it called oh it's
cold
we are never ever ever getting back
together forget that you sing at the
most inappropriate times it's awful
well what do you mean Erin you just hear
anything and you think of a lyric and
you turn it into a musical and it's
terrible oh my god Erin what's wrong why
are you crying
my boyfriend six ears oh honey I'm so
sorry it's just we've been together for
so long we were both so yeah we were
both young when I first saw you
I'll close my eyes and the flashback
start and they're exactly you know what
I'm glad you brought that up because she
is killing me every week I got a little
bit [ __ ] because she and I go out you
know okay okay
okay guys I get it I can't sing but I
enjoy it okay I enjoy a good melody is
that such a freakin crime it is a crime
hell yeah it's a crime oh oh really
please oh yeah you do this we're gonna
talk about all my flaws sit here and
talk about some yours shall we Kelis you
drop the n-bomb way too much yeah that's
right ever since you found out you're a
quarter black that's been half the damn
vocabulary right there pop
pop [ __ ] pat-pat-pat make it make - its
spherical [ __ ] whoa I brought your ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] Chris Chris look at me you
fart when you get nervous and it's
disgusting hey Paul Paul you sound black
as hell what for real don't paper bark
burn that's what I've just said burn
point proven
G oh don't laugh oh you know you smell
like [ __ ] smells like a skunk just
crawled all up in your mouth and just
[ __ ] himself and Aaron threes the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that you just come she just call me
faculty you see now you're just being
ridiculous because I'm not fed khlifa
now we've been going to the clip show
your arms we got the same size arms
right honey
honey you have to tease no fake titties
when you jump around and you're jumping
jacks
it looks like the beginning to a
softcore porn okay is this because we
split the bill early you see oh my god
alright everyone get up we're going on a
field trip and I'm gonna show you
something
[Music]
yes yeah okay babe what is this
it's a garage gate and what happens when
cars Shive up to the gate David it opens
up I wonder so what the whole point of
this is all right well I'm gonna explain
it to you if you could just step back I
want everyone else to walk up the gate
okay now I want David to walk up to the
gate all by himself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]